هل سيتم اعتقال ترامب وماذا سيحدث اذا تم
توقيف ترامب اليوم البدايه كانت من الرئيس
الامريكي السابق نفسه حين قال عبر منصته
يتروس سوشيال ميديا انه يتوقع توقيفه
اليوم الثلاثاء في قضيه دسيد مبلغ من
المال في عام 2016
لممثله اباحيه يعتقد انه كان على علاقه
بها المدعي العام في منهاتن ابلغ وهو
ديمقراطي طبعا اتهم باستهداف ترامب لتحقيق
مكاسب سياسيه وقد يستخدم الرئيس السابق
هذا الادعاء اساسا في دفاعه عن نفسه ضد
التهم الموجهه اليه ويمكنه ايضا الطعم
فيما اذا كانت فتره التقادم الفتره التي
يحق فيها للشخص تقديم دعوه قضائيه جراء
الضرر الذي حصل له قد انتهت من الناحيه
السياسيه مشاهدينا من غير الواضح كيف يمكن
لاي لائحه اتهام ان تؤثر على فرص ترامب في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لعام 2024 لكنه سيكون
اول رئيس امريكي سابق يواجه محاكمه جنائيه
واذا تم ترشيحه للانتخابات بالفعل قد
يحاكم ترامب اثناء حملته الانتخابيه في
عام 2024 وهو حدث غير مسبوق طبعا واذا تم
انتخابه رئيسا للولايات المتحده مره اخرى
فلن تكون لديه القدره على العفو عن نفسه
من التهم الجنائيه المنسوبه اليها
[موسيقى]
كيف ستسير اجراءات توقيف ترامب هذا السؤال
يقول بانه تتطلب اي لائحه اتهام من ترامب
السفر من فلوريدا حيث يعيش الى مكتب
المدعي العام في نيويورك وطبعا هناك
للاستسلام ونظرا لكون قضيه راب من ضمن
قضايا اصحاب الياقات البيضاء وهي تلك التي
تتعلق بالجرائم غير العنيفه المرتكبه من
قبل رجال الاعمال واصحاب النفوذ فقد يذهب
ترامب طوعا الى السلطات حيث سيتم تصويره
واخذ بصمات اصابعه قبل مثوله امام المحكمه
وعلى اي حال قدر الخبراء القانونيون بان
اي محاكمه للرئيس الامريكي الصادق ترامب
ستكون باكثر من عام او بعد اكثر من عام
واذا حدث ذلك فقد تتزامن المحاكمه مع
الاشهر الاخيره من انتخابات عام
2024 التي يسعى فيها ترامب للعوده والعوده
مثيره الجدل الى البيت الابيض
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ايام ايام
[تصفيق]